schönen guten abend aus kiew in die
runde mittlerweile gehen wir in die
dritte woche oder die vierte woche
bereits des gesamten krieges gegen die
ukraine ich weiß nicht ob es ein guter
abend ist denn gerade eben sind wieder
sirenen los gegangen und wir haben im
nordosten direkt hinter uns bei einer
live schalte die explosionen sehen
können das ist wie ein feuerball der
dann da in der nacht zu sehen ist und
heute den ganzen tag über gab es bereits
horrornachrichten auch hier aus kiew am
morgen wurde ein wohnhaus
angegriffen es gab mehrere tote
mindestens zwei mehrere verletzte danach
würde ich mit den beiden
klitschko-brüdern zu einem weiteren
tatort so nenne ich es ein tatort der
von putins raketen angegriffen wurde ein
bus völlig zerstört ein haus wir haben
dort leichen gesehen und kiews
bürgermeister vitali klitschko an der
seite sein bruder wladimir klitschko war
nur noch fassungslos als ich mit ihnen
dort durch die komplett fast zerstörte
straße gelaufen bin und vitali klitschko
hat dennoch gesagt wir werden nicht
aufgeben wir werden nicht aufhören uns
hier zu verteidigen aber das was heute
in kiel passiert ist das was wir gesehen
haben in kiew lässt schlimmes vermuten
für die nächsten tage und wochen und
möglicherweise ist es so dass die
scheinbar an friedensverhandlungen von
putin nur angeboten wurden um hier
weiteres unheil anzurichten weitere
menschen die sterben müssen und die
ukraine die bitten verzweifelt und sagen
schwert endlich den luftraum und gibt
uns mehr waffen
[Musik]
herr doktor mölling wenn sie das hören
wie könnte man denn diesen krieg beenden
was muss passieren nun könnte man
vielleicht ja doch da noch aufeinander
zugehen oder wie soll man sich
eigentlich gegenüber dem aggressor
wladimir putin falken ja ich habe wir
sehen ja gerade das ist auf der einen
seite schon gespräch sagen angebote aus
der ukraine heraus gibt es gibt den
glaube schon in wild zu verhandelnden
selensky sieht dass er das nicht
unendlich durchhalten kann aber es ist
die russische seite sich bewegen muss
europa die nato hat die können hier
nicht mithelfen das sind die beiden
parteien die im grund genommen zum
schluss kommen müssen wir haben aber
jetzt zur zeit eine situation immer noch
wo man sagen muss dass muss dann im
golem die pistole an den kopf der
ukraine hält und das sind keine fairen
verhandlungen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt es
gibt immer noch eine kapitulation und
deswegen ist der widerstand der zeit
stattfindet in kiew und in der gesamten
ukraine so wichtig in der kauft uns zeit
damit dass die dass die sanktionen
wirken können und damit die situation
für putin schwerere wird
das thema sanktionen wurde gerade
angesprochen du bist vor ort wenigen die
menschen es dort auch was wollen sie von
europa und ich weiß gar nicht immer wenn
du es erklärt wie ich die bilder
kommentieren soll weil sie so furchtbar
sind aber was wird jetzt erwartet wie
kann wie kann es also was kann man tun
wenn wir es jetzt nicht noch in woche 4
5 6 7 8 9 und die nächsten monate läuft
dieser schreckliche krieg
ja ich glaube dass der ukrainische
präsident unbedingt verhandeln will er
sagt ja auch immer wieder dass er mit
wladimir putin an einen tisch will und
angeblich wollen will die russische
regierung das ja auch so tun sie
zumindest allerdings ist es so dass sie
ihre bedingungen formulieren und da sind
bedingungen dabei die für den
ukrainischen präsidenten nur schwer zu
akzeptieren sind und selbst wenn er sie
akzeptieren würde man davon ausgehen
muss dass die bevölkerung sie nicht
akzeptieren würde nämlich vor allem die
frage einer demilitarisierung also einem
land das gerade dabei ist sich zu
verteidigen gegen russland dieses land
dazu zu bringen zu sein wir geben unser
militär völlig auf ist eigentlich so gut
wie unmöglich und sehr schwer wird es
auch bei der frage was mit den regionen
passiert die bereits von moskau von
russland von der russischen armee
erobert wurden zum beispiel einzelne
große städte wo man ja sehen kann dass
die bevölkerung eben nicht darauf
gewartet hat dass die russische armee
dort ist und dass die russische flagge
gehisst wird sondern ganz im gegenteil
wir dort sehen dass ukraine mutige
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer weiter auf
die straße gehen und gegen diese
russische armee gegen diese besetzung
demonstrieren also es ist auch für den
ukrainischen präsidenten ein schweres
moralisches dilemma auf der einen seite
will er diesen krieg beenden auf der
anderen seite weiß er dass er ihn nicht
mit unter allen bedingungen beenden
gehalt beenden kann denn wenn er das
macht was putin will dann ist die
ukraine geschichte
herr scheuer wir sind ja gerade
naja die union regiert jetzt gerade
nicht mehr sie sind der opposition denn
gerade die regierung einen guten job mit
blick auf putins krieg zum einen muss
man sagen dass die opposition aus cdu
und csu
vernünftig ist zusammensteht mit den
herausforderungen in der welt ich weiß
dass es viele gespräche gibt auch mit
den
regierungsvertretern und unseren
fraktionsvorsitzenden parteivorsitzenden
ich finde das gut weil ich glaube wir
müssen als westliche welt zusammenstehen
das was wir einfordern hat wirkung
nämlich dass ein stehen in europa
zusammen auch im bündnis mit der nato
das denke ich hat große wirkung gezeigt
davon ist putin sicherlich überrascht
von der geschlossenheit an dieser stelle
dennoch gibt es natürlich einige themen
die man anders machen würden und wir
würden natürlich auch gerade den
bundeskanzler in einer noch stärkeren
rolle gerne sehen da haben wir
dazugelernt nach angela merkel ist
die spitze der bundesregierung doch ein
bisschen ruhiger zurückhaltender als es
noch die zeit vorher war also wenn in
israel dann verhandelt werden soll auf
neutralem boden zum einen beantragt die
ukraine die eu mitgliedschaft und dann
schaue ich mir marco scholz an dann
würde ich mir da mehr erwarten aber das
ist eine randbemerkung wir müssen jetzt
zusammenstehen als deutsche für den
frieden und wenn man diese bilder sieht
und ja auch was die reporter die
journalisten dort leisten ich kann nur
meine hohen respekt zollen aber ich habe
gerade aktuellen bericht eines
landesgruppenvorsitzenden alexander
dobrindt gehörte mit einer kleinen
delegation an der polnischen grenze war
gerade die polen leisten da immenses in
der aufnahme von flüchtlingen und wir
müssen uns vorbereiten und da fordere
ich von der bundesregierung mehr aktion
auf eine riesige flüchtlingswelle
die vielleicht auch von anderen
ausgenutzt wird diese flüchtlingswelle
auch schleuserbanden haben das schon
gemerkt also das sind alles
erscheinungen entwicklungen denen wir
uns stellen müssen und wo wir unsere
humanitäre kraft einbringen müssen
trotzdem die herausforderungen werden
von tag zu tag größer nicht nur im
kriegsgebiet sondern die auswirkungen
auf europa ohnehin und das immer noch
nicht einmal bei den energiepreisen und
vieles mehr herr mordhorst sie sind bei
der fdp und dementsprechend können sie
eigentlich direkt darauf ein steinmeier
gesagt ja selbstverständlich also im
grundsatz glaube ich sind wir uns da
auch sehr sehr einig es ist wichtig
insbesondere aufgrund unserer
außenpolitische verlässlichkeit die
putin glaube ich auch wirklich
überrascht hat das stimme ich zu dass
wir jetzt auch zumindest was die
staatstragenden parteien angeht
zusammenstehen deswegen unterstütze ich
das durchaus und es stimmt wir sind auf
große wellen vorbereitet was die
flüchtlinge angeht polen leistet
immenses wir haben erste zahlen das ist
so ungefähr ein drittel dessen was 2014
bis 17 kamen nach deutschland kam jetzt
schon bei uns angekommen ist immer noch
kein vergleich zu polen aber völlig
richtig wir müssen uns darauf
vorbereiten darauf vorbereiten bin der
überzeugung sowohl was man
beispielsweise hier am berliner
hauptbahnhof sieht wo freiwillige helfer
außerordentliches leisten aber auch
ansonsten ist die politik darauf gut
vorbereitet und die aufnahmebereitschaft
der menschen ist auch etwas was mich
jeden tag mit respekt erfüllt und
beeindruckt ihr motto was darf ich das
nur sagen ich würde mir wünschen so eine
organisatorische professionalität von
dem aktuellen bericht aus dieser
delegation die von uns dort an der
grenze war mit softwareunterstützung mit
aller registrierungen mit
organisatorischen abläufen dass das auch
zum beispiel am berliner hauptbahnhof an
dieser stelle neben der humanitären
verantwortung neben dem was die menschen
an leisten die hilfsorganisationen sehe
ich doch bei den großen mengen schon
noch organisatorisch nachholbedarf in
deutschland und das müssen wir heute
gemeinsam verantwortung zusammen mit den
bundesländern und den kommunen
hinbekommen aber trotzdem wir müssen uns
auch auf das vorbereiten dass die
kriegshandlungen dazu führen dass nicht
nur frauen und kinder flüchten und
kommen sondern dass auch noch mal
größere flüchtlingsströme zu uns kommen
die wir dann versorgen müssen aufnehmen
müssen auch vielleicht sogar medizinisch
versorgen müssen ich nehme das mal sehr
ernsthaft mit ich will das gar nicht
parteipolitisch jetzt irgendwie
aufdröseln ich habe erst heute wieder
mit einem vertreter der freiwilligen
helfer gesprochen der auch uns da sehr
genau ideen und rückmeldung gegeben hat
also wir bleiben da im austausch und ich
glaube das ist auch vernünftig so
ich habe ja ich hab dich eh schon gehört
dann
ich störe ja diesen diesen frieden
sozusagen jetzt im doppelten sinne dann
nur sehr ungerne wie sie sich alle auf
die schulter klopfen wie großartig
deutschland das macht und wie toll wir
helfen ja die menschen helfen die bürger
helfen das stimmt auf der anderen seite
sollte man sich in sollte man nicht
aufhören sie unangenehme fragen zu
stellen denn
sie tun jetzt so als wäre das gegeben da
hat der krieg wird derzeit viel
schlimmer und dann sterben mehr menschen
und mehr menschen flüchten und wir tun
so als hätten wir schon alles getan um
den menschen hier zu helfen das haben
wir nämlich nicht gerade eben vor 8
minuten hat das estnische parlament
übrigens ein nato-mitglied dafür
gestimmt eine flugverbotszone
einzurichten das bedeutet erstmal gar
nichts aber es zeigt dass es durchaus
staaten gibt in der nato und insgesamt
auch in europa die dazu bereit sind der
ukraine zu helfen im weiteren sinn wie
in deutschland wir waren nicht mal
bereit ein öl- und gas-embargo
mitzutragen was die usa zum beispiel
längst beschlossen haben ich muss sagen
wenn ich hier in der ukraine unterwegs
bin und nicht leute treffe die ich nicht
ohnehin schon kenne also ich weiß nicht
ob ich immer noch im ersten satz sagen
paul von germany ja also manchmal
habe ich das gefühl langsam ihr in der
ukraine
da versteht keiner mehr was unser
bundeskanzler olaf scholz da macht das
die bundesregierung da macht warum sie
wieder so halbherzig agiert warum sie
zwar sanktionen umsetzt aber nicht so
entscheidend dass sie wirklich
überraschen können und da würde ich auch
ein scheuer widersprechen dass putin mit
irgendeiner form mit diesen sanktionen
nicht gerechnet hätte wir müssen bei den
punkt bleiben dass wir weiterhin
milliarden einem diktator und einem
kriegsverbrecher überweisen da können
sich jetzt noch so häufig auf die
schulter klopfen wie toll wir alles
machen
also vielleicht kann ich ja noch mal
zwei punkte zu bringen flugverbotszone
erstens heißt krieg eintritt der nato
das heißt wir stellen gegen russische
flugzeuge ab egal ob es jetzt sogar im
westen oder über die gesamte ukraine
machen das ist ein risiko insbesondere
unter der bedingung dass die russischen
truppen jetzt schon auf konventionell
seite so schlecht aufgestellt sind dass
uns an die nukleare schwelle deutlich
näher dran bringt das ist für uns das
dilemma diese verantwortung müssen wir
irgendwann übernehmen und dazu sagen wir
zurzeit nein das würde ich unterstützen
ich gebe ihn runter aber insofern recht
die diskussion über die tagespolitik ist
schön und gut dieser konflikt wird in
zwei wochen ganz anders aussehen wir
werden in zwei wochen massiven beschuss
der ballungszentren haben wahrscheinlich
auch von kiew noch mehr schreckliche
bilder noch mehr flüchtlinge nicht durch
den beschuss die sind jetzt auf dem weg
zu uns und wir müssen uns darauf
einstellen dass das einfach selbst wenn
irgendwann der schieß krieg aufhört
keinen frieden gibt das heißt die
sanktionen wenn wir über jahre hinweg
aufrecht erhalten müssen diese welt wird
danach eine andere sein die
sicherheitsoffensive vorher mal geglaubt
haben zu haben wird es nicht mehr geben
wir werden entweder eine friedensordnung
haben die ohne russland funktioniert
oder notfall sogar gegen russland
funktionieren muss
und ich bin dafür dass wir uns selber
nicht schwächen nur ein starkes
deutschland ein starkes europa aber es
die
energielieferungen betrifft kann dann in
der folge helfen wenn wir selber die
auswirkungen zu spüren bekommen und wir
spüren sie ja jetzt schon dann glaube
ich ist das viel zu kurz gesprungen ich
weiß dass er uns haben wir natürlich
jetzt in einem einsatz ist der alles
emotionale auch abverlangt und wir
können von diesem schönen studie aus gar
nicht beurteilen was vorleistungen
gemacht werden nur ich sage nochmal auch
usa handelt jetzt nicht als
allumfassende nur an andere denken
sondern da gibt es auch eine strategie
america first als stichwort um zu sagen
ich versuche mich jetzt mit meiner
eigenen energie oder die andere
partnerschaften
danke dass sie das so sagen ja ich
glaube ich stimme dir voll und ganz
hermeling zu denn wir befinden uns
gerade in einer ganz harten
auseinandersetzung über politische
systeme mittel und langfristig stichwort
china stichwort die ausrichtung also
wenn jetzt russland zum discountpreis
billigst energie nach china liefern kann
dann geht der der spread immer weiter
auseinander china kann noch günstiger
produzieren noch intensiver den
weltmarkt eintritt machen und in europa
wird deutschland am stärksten geschwächt
und das will ich nicht weil wir wenn wir
stark bleiben dann können wir auch
unseren beitrag leisten unsere stärke
geht über die wirtschaft und diesen
rückstoß der sanktionen den erleben wir
heute schon und der darf nicht stärker
wir reden wir jetzt auch gleich mit
ihnen herr marc kast ich möchte aber
noch einmal ein paar fragen und noch
etwas ein gegner werden das ist ja seine
these heute abend bevor wir dann zur
nächsten tieren sie kommen zu den
energiepreisen
hast mich gehört
ich habe dich gehört ich habe gerade
eine nachricht entgegen genommen über
einen verletzten foxnews journalisten
das musste ich einmal hier wahrnehmen
also gestern ist er bereits ein us
kollege bei der berichterstattung muss
leben gekommen und ein weiterer foxnews
kollege benjamin horn ist verletzt
worden außerhalb von kiew es gibt
bislang noch nicht genügend
informationen offenbar das ist gerade
eine mitteilung die von fox news
veröffentlicht wurde das musste ich nur
einmal zur kenntnis nehmen
weil da weiß man nie was man erwidern
soll sondern dass hoffentlich alle
journalisten auch dort gut auf sich
aufpassen aber da möchte ich dir dann
einfach noch eine frage stellen du hast
in einem interview gesagt dass solange
journalisten vor ort sind und auch die
geschichte zeigt wieder das risiko was
ihr alle auf euch nehmt dass es dann ein
kleines stück sicherer für die menschen
ist wie auch in anderen kriegsgebieten
wie wäre es denn eigentlich mit
politikern würde es irgend etwas bringen
wenn mehr politiker europäische
politiker deutsche politiker auch nach
kiew reisen würden
ja
sicherlich wobei die frage ist sozusagen
wenn politiker irgendwohin reisen dann
muss es mehr sein als das ich fand den
vorschlag von wladimir klitschko in dem
fall eigentlich sehr gute gefordert
hatte dass zum beispiel der papst nach
kiel kommen sollte und weitere anführer
verschiedener religionen dass sie hier
ein treffen veranstalten sollten um ihre
solidarität mit den menschen in der
ukraine auszudrücken und da würde ich
noch viel er ja sagen
wenn wann ich jetzt könnte auch die
katholische kirche vielleicht sogar mit
ein bisschen eigennutz wenn man darüber
denkt wie viele negative schlagzeilen
sie produziert haben in den vergangenen
jahren und wie viel schlimmes dort
zutage getreten ist der papst rief ich
glaube das wäre ein richtiges signal